I don't lose or break my moscots and I
do with all my other sunglasses and I
don't know if that's the way they're
made I don't know if it's my attitude to
them or maybe what I think is probably
most likely is that they just have
magical powers
hi GQ I'm Taryn Edgerton and these are
my essentials
[Music]
you get asked quite often what are your
vices what are the things you spend
money on
and for some people his cars luxury
vacations or beautiful clothes
mine is candles
Elton John introduced me to this candle
Elton has this specific fragrance
burning in any room he's in and somehow
he manages to get them burning in the
room before he arrives unfortunately I
don't have elton's money
so it's a big incentive for me to keep
working this candle should come with a
Barry White mixtape because it is a very
that's quite a sexy smell
so it kind of smells like quite
tobacco in I think it might be like a
bit Sandalwood like
smells like magic might happen tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
this bracelet was given to me on my 30th
birthday by Legend Lyricist Bernie
tolpin we were still promoting rocket
man it was in November of 2019 and he
was kind of infuriated that no one had
told him it was my birthday so he pulled
it from his own wrist and gave it to me
and told me that he'd been wearing it
for decades we were in the middle of
telling the story of his life as well as
Elton John's and he was pleased enough
and proud enough to give me this off his
wrist and so I treasure it some people
can wear clothes and jewelry and just
own it instantly and I don't always feel
that way but there's something about
this I think because of the story behind
it I feel very comfortable in it and I
feel like it's mine and I feel like I
wear it because he gave it to me
[Music]
my beach film the first thing I do in
the morning is play music and it's the
last thing I do before bed kaytranada is
quite a good guy bad music
sleepy music would be like
Nick Drake
for the next level there's something
about this specific speaker it looks
kind of bashed up but it still works
beautifully and it's got like this
rubber strip around it which means if I
drop it because I'm tearing up the dance
floor in my hotel suite I know it's
gonna bounce back
foreign
[Music]
large slash extra large baseball cap
yeah I mean I'm not famous enough to
forever be being handed by people but
there's something about a baseball cap
that makes me feel like I just can
disappear and it feels like a suit of
armor and obviously you know every every
second day is a bad hair day so it helps
with that too I've worn one for as long
as I can remember normally in Navy
sometimes in Black if I'm feeling dark
and edgy you know not having that
would make me want to turn around and
drive back to my house even if I left 30
minutes ago
[Music]
I love this cardigan by an LA based
company called elder Statesman I have a
couple of these in these really funky
colors I mean it's the kind of thing
that I might wear out about in LA but in
London for some reason I don't know what
it is but in London I feel too like I'm
peacocking because they're quite loud
and I feel like in LA people are much
less judgmental about that but in London
I always feel more of a pressure to just
be kind of
to be cool and be you know anyway I have
three in my house and whenever my mother
or my stepfather or my little sisters
come and stay they always get
commandeered and they sit and chill and
watch movies in these so I'm forever
picking out little bits of sticky
popcorn from them hey that's the Perils
of having your family comes to stay
a couple of things in my list are maybe
a little bougier a little more fancy
than I actually am so I'm glad these are
here because I feel they're kind of more
reflective of who I really am they're
like a great basic sneaker I love the
humble Nike Blazer I also like a flat
bottom sneaker I don't like it when
there's like curvature at the side it
looked great on some people it just
doesn't look great on me I really feel
like if they're a box fresh pair they
can look quite smart but they also age
beautifully I did have a real Rough and
Ready pair that I was too embarrassed to
bring today because
I don't know I normally travel with a
pair that's like a newer pair and then a
pair that looks more tired as well
depending on what I'm gonna wear it with
these are moscots and I have like a lot
of pears in this shape in different
colors different tints
and I just think they shoot my face and
it's not the case with all sunglasses
you know that thing where you're in the
store it's a bit like when they put the
Sorting Hat on those kids heads just
instantly puts them in the right house
sunglasses like that for me and a lot I
don't feel good in but I always feel
good in a pair of muscles I don't lose
or break my muscles and I do with all my
other sunglasses and I don't know if
that's the way they're made I don't know
if it's my attitude to them or maybe
what I think is probably most likely is
that they just have magical powers
foreign
learning about myself and my
relationship with clothes like when I
try and do like fashion it doesn't work
I always feel almost happy and most
comfortable in things that I feel are
timers and the classic white tea Allah
James Dean or Marlon Brando like I am
not comparing myself to those guys but
aspirationally that's what I'd be aiming
for this is specifically a sunspell it's
a British brand in a cut they called the
Riviera which was I think it was
designed for Daniel Craig for one of his
first out of things as Bond I'll either
wear a medium or a large
depending on whatever else I'm wearing
and
how many burgers I've had that month
[Music]
this is actually not something I really
like about myself but I just can't sleep
without an eye mask don't know what it
is don't know when it started sometime
in my 20s but I really struggle without
it now I don't know if it comes from
sleeping on planes or life of an actor
you know not often being in your own bed
they have short lives that I mean I
slept in this one last night this is an
art Department it really is this scruffy
and and fatty and disgusting
I will have a fresher one soon
[Music]
Armani blue is my
the fragrance that I wear all the time I
don't have like one that you know some
people have like an evening every day I
just wear my blue
it's it's like fresh and citrusy but
it's also got an evening to it this is a
bit of a name drop it was first sent to
me by Roberto Armani and I hasten to add
I am not paid by Armani I really do just
love the fragrance it's not something I
wear every day because there's something
quite elevated about a fragrance I think
and I can smell it on myself
but sometimes it's also nice to be a
little bit
extra and when I want to be a little bit
extra I wear a money blue
thank you for having me GQ I hope you've
enjoyed watching and listening to me
talk about my essentials